how many holes
does a straw have and you listener
may uh try to answer that in your own
head yeah i'm gonna take a drink while
everybody thinks about it a slow sip
is it uh zero one
or two or more more than that maybe
maybe you get very creative
but uh it's kind of interesting to uh
each
uh dissecting each answer as you do in
the book is quite brilliant people
should definitely check it out but
if you could try to answer it now like
think about
all the options and why they may or may
not be right
yeah it's one it's one of these
questions where people on first hearing
it think it's a triviality and they're
like well the answer is obvious and then
what happens if you ever ask a group of
people this something
wonderfully comic happens which is that
everyone's like well it's completely
obvious
and then each person realizes that half
the person the other people in the room
have a different
obvious answer for the way that they
have and then people get really heated
people are like
i can't believe that you think it has
two holes or like i can't believe that
you think it has one
and then you know you really like people
really learn something about each other
and people
get heated i mean can we go through the
possible options here
is it zero one two three ten
sure so i think you know most people
the zero holders are rare they would say
like well look
you can make a straw by taking a
rectangular piece of plastic and closing
it up the rectangular piece of plastic
doesn't have a hole in it
uh i didn't poke a hole in it
so how can i have a hole they'd like
it's just one thing okay
most people don't see it that way that's
like uh um
is there any truth to that kind of
conception yeah i think that would be
somebody whose account
i mean
what i would say is you could say the
same thing
um about a bagel you could say i can
make a bagel by taking like a long
cylinder of dough which doesn't have a
hole and then smushing the ends together
now it's a bagel so if you're really
committed you can be like okay bagel
doesn't have a hole either but like
who are you if you say a bagel doesn't
at all i mean i don't know yeah so
that's almost like an engineering
definition of it
okay fair enough so what's what about
the other options
um so you know one whole people
would say um i like how these are like
groups of people
like where we've planted our foot yes
there's books written about each belief
you know would say look there's like a
hole and it goes all the way through the
straw right there's it's
one region of space that's the hole yeah
and there's one
and two whole people would say like look
there's a hole in the top in the hole
at the bottom um i think a common thing
you see
when people um
argue about this they would take
something like this uh bottle of water
i'm holding maybe i'll open it and they
say well how many holes are there in
this and you say like well there's one
there's one hole
at the top okay what if i like poke a
hole here so that all the water
spills out well now it's a straw
yeah so if you're a one hole or i say to
you like well how many holes are
in it now there was a there was one hole
in it before and i poked a new hole in
it
and then you think there's still one
hole even though there was
one hole and i made one more clearly not
this is two holes
yeah um and yet if you're a two-hole or
the one holder will say like okay where
does one hole begin in the other whole
end
yeah like what's it like and um
and in the in the book i sort of you
know in math there's two things we do
when we're faced with a problem that's
confusing us
um we can make the problem simpler
that's what we were doing a minute ago
and we were talking about high
dimensional space and i was like let's
talk about like circles and line
segments let's like go down a dimension
to make it easier
uh the other big move we have is to make
the problem harder
and try to sort of really like face up
to what are the complications so
you know what i do in the book is say
like let's stop talking about straws for
a minute and talk about pants
how many holes are there in a pair of
pants
so i think most people who say there's
two holes in the straw would say there's
three holes in a pair of pants
i guess i mean i guess we're filming
only from here i could take up no i'm
not going to do it
you'll just have to imagine the pants
sorry yeah um
lex if you want it no okay no
uh that's gonna be in the direction
that's the patreon only footage
there you go so many people would say
there's three holes in a pair of pants
but you know for instance my daughter
when i asked this by the way talking to
kids about this
is super fun i highly recommend it um
what did she say
she said well yeah i feel a pair of
pants like just has two holes because
yes there's the waist but that's just
the two leg holes stuck together
whoa okay two legs yeah okay right i
mean that's she's a one caller
for the straw so she's the one holder
for the straw too and um
and that really does capture something
it captures this fact which is central
to the theory of what's called homology
which is like a central part of modern
topology that
um holes whatever we may mean by them
there are somehow things which have an
arithmetic to them they're things which
can be added
like the waist like waist equals leg
plus leg is kind of an equation but it's
not an equation about
numbers it's an equation about some kind
of geometric some kind of topological
thing which is very strange and so
you know when i come down um
you know like a rabbi i like to kind of
like come up with these answers and
somehow like
dodge the original question and say like
you're both right my children okay so
yeah uh so for this for the
for the straw i think what a modern
mathematician would say is like
the first version would be to say like
well there are two holes but they're
really both the same hole
well that's not quite right a better way
to say it is there's two holes
but one is the negative of the other now
what can that mean
um one way of thinking about what it
means is that if you sip something like
a milkshake through the straw
no matter what the amount of milkshake
that's flowing in one end
that same amount is flowing out the
other end
so they're not independent from each
other there's some relationship
between them in the same way that if you
somehow could like suck a milkshake
through a pair of pants
the amount of milkshake just go with me
on this not experimenting
mom right there the amount of milkshake
that's coming in the left leg of the
pants
plus the amount of milkshake that's
coming in the right leg of the pants
is the same that's coming out the uh the
waist of the pants so just so you know i
fasted for 72 hours
yesterda uh the last three days so i
just broke the fast with a little bit of
food yesterday so this is like this
sounds
uh food analogies or metaphors for this
podcast work wonderfully because i can
intensely picture it is that your weekly
routine or just in preparation for
talking about geometry for three hours
yeah exactly this is the question for
this it's hardship
to purify the mind no it's for the first
time i just wanted to try the experience
oh wow
and just to uh to pause to do things
that are out of the ordinary to pause
and to uh reflect on how grateful i am
to be
just alive and be able to do all the
cool [ __ ] that i get to do so did you
drink water
yes yes yes yes yes water and salt
so like electrolytes and all those kinds
of things but anyway
so the inflow on the top of the pans
equals
to the outflow on the bottom of the
pants
exactly so this idea that
i mean i think you know poincare really
have these i this idea this sort of
modern idea
i mean building on stuff other people
did uh betty is an important one
of this kind of modern notion of
relations between holes but the idea
that holes really had an arithmetic
the really modern view was really emmy
nerder's idea so she kind of comes in
and sort of
truly puts the subject uh on its modern
footing that we have
that we have now so you know it's always
a challenge you know in the book
i'm not gonna say i give like a course
so that you read this chapter and then
you're like oh it's just like i took
like
a semester of algebraic apology it's not
like this and it's always a you know
it's always a challenge
writing about math because there are
some things
that you can really do on the page and
the math is there
and there's other things which it's too
much in a book like this like do them
all the page you can only
say something about them if that makes
sense um
so you know in the book i try to do some
of both i try to do i try to
topics that are you can't really
compress
and really truly say exactly what they
are
in this amount of space um
i try to say something interesting about
them something meaningful about them so
that readers can get the flavor
um and then in other places i really try
to get up close and personal
and really do the math and have it take
place on the page
to some degree be able to give
inklings of the beauty of the subject
yeah i mean there's you know there's a
lot of books that are like
i don't quite know how to express this
well i'm still laboring to do it but
um there's a lot of books that are about
stuff
but i want my books to not only be about
stuff but to actually have some stuff
there on the page
in the book for people to interact with
directly and not just sort of hear me
talk about distant features about
just distant features of it
you